at this altitude I can run flat out for
a half mile before my hands start
shaking you know I also do personal
question now it is soon
I'm a cybernetic organism living tissue
over metal endoskeleton hello my lovely
listeners I have a very important update
so thank you for listening to this short
message in its entirety there have been
some new bits added I'm removing ads and
sponsors from the podcast for a plan six
month test and I'll explain why I'm
doing that if the response is mostly
crickets it could end sooner as this is
a very expensive roll of the dice the
podcast has become the economic engine
that fuels and enables everything else
which is pretty funny to consider when
you look back and see what at lark it
began has nonetheless the podcast allows
me to do all sorts of cool things that I
can share and that I hope will have a
great impact in the world it gives me
the financial slack to also do that for
instance supporting scientific research
for treatment-resistant depression at
johns hopkins hiring staff to help with
publishing three books for free if you
look up top Seneca helping to establish
the world's first Center for psychedelic
research at Imperial College in London
and also recently completing a pro bono
launch of a powerful documentary about
treatment of PTSD called trip of
compassion all that stuff is not
possible without the kind of slack in
the system financially and also as a
platform that the podcast provides so
why change anything why would I do that
but I will I will tell you that there
are some very good reasons number one I
would really like a more direct
relationship with my most dedicated
listeners readers and fans
number two sponsors and ads troupe a ton
of time that I'd rather spend finding
and doing cool things I can share with
you
I don't think advertising is evil it
works really well but the sponsorship
model consumes a lot of my time and
energy a lot of my team's time and
energy I'd rather focus on the stuff
that probably brought you to my books or
the podcast in the first place and
number three over the years thousands of
readers and fans have asked me how can I
thank you aside from buying the books
and this is an option for them so what
do you get if you
to support the podcast you get a new
upgraded option you get exclusive access
to me and a small tribe of like-minded
people
and you can learn more at teamed up log
forward slashes support here's what yet
once a month I'll be doing an hour-long
live video Q&A just for this much
smaller group of supporters you can ask
me anything and only supporters get to
participate and ask questions the first
one will be on July 1st and you'll get
notified via email if you can't make it
live each session will be available to
supporters right afterwards is recording
and if the audio is ever shared on the
podcast will be delayed by at least a
month and those are the basics you can
learn more at teamed up log forward
slash support as I mentioned the podcast
has become the economic engine that kind
of drives everything else so if this
really does not work we're gonna go back
to sponsors but I hope it works we shall
find out yeah so if you'd like to test
out a more direct connection and
interaction with me
check out Tim vlog for slash support if
any of the hundreds of blog posts or
podcasts or if any of the books about an
impact on you or the people you care
about please consider it you can think
of it as a monthly gym membership for
your mind and career and I look forward
to your questions when I do the first
live video Q&A on July 1st so check it
out tuned up log forward slash support
and thank you so much for listening
hello boys and girls ladies and germs
this is Tim Ferriss and welcome to
another episode of the Tim Ferriss show
where it is my job each in every episode
to deconstruct world-class performers
from all different disciplines and my
guest today has a very very interesting
job and that is he himself I would say
deconstructs and helps to reconstruct
world-class performers his name is Jerry
Kelowna CEO l ona on twitter at Jericho
onna he is the CEO and co-founder of
reboot IO
an executive coaching and leadership
development firm dedicated to the notion
that better humans make better leaders
prior to his career as a coach he was a
partner with JPMorgan partners JP MP the
private equity arm of JP Morgan Chase
and part of that he led New York
city-based Flatiron Partners you may
have heard of it
which he co-founded in 1996 with Fred
Wilson Flatiron became one of the
nation's most successful early stage
investment programs and certainly those
in the adventure game no that is
understated his first ever leadership
position at age 25 was editor-in-chief
of information Week magazine and now
returning to the written word his first
book is reboot subtitle leadership and
the art of growing up Jerry
welcome to the show hey Tim it's great
to be here I'm really excited to talk to
you we have so much we could possibly
talk about you and I have spoken before
had quite a few conversations over the
last god knows how many years I think
with protein density a handful of years
ago and I thought we could start with
the spider tattoo which you just showed
me over video it is not a small tattoo
so perhaps much like a novel I greatly
enjoy the girl with the dragon tattoo
this would be the coach with the spider
tattoo but I don't know the story why do
you have a gigantic spider tattoo on
your chest oh well yeah so spider is a
good friend of mine spider is my spirit
so in 2007 I went on a retreat led by a
union eco psychologist named Bill
Plotkin PLO t ki n and on that retreat
is a long story Tim be ready for it oh
I'm naughty on that retreat I started to
go really deep into some of the
important structures of my life
and I had a dream and it was after a
night of ecstatic dancing in which I
danced nearly naked in a drum circle and
I'd fallen asleep and I had this dream
in which I was supposed to I was going
to a house that I owned on Long Island
and I got to the house and the house was
completely white and I was really
terrified and I went into the house and
it was supposed to be my house but it
didn't feel right and I ended up in the
basement and in the basements basement
floor was covered with this sort of like
the floor of a forest and these
mushrooms were sprouting up and I got
very scared and I tore the mushrooms
from the ground and I ran out of the
house so the next morning I went into
circle again and I shared that dream and
Bill turns to me and he says go leave
leave the circle right now I want you to
go into the forest I want you to find
those mushrooms and I want you to
apologize to those mushrooms and ask it
what it was that you were supposed to
hear from them that you were too afraid
to hear
so I left the circle and I started
wandering around and I'm like what the
[ __ ] am i doing I'm walking around this
forest trying to find these mushrooms
and I actually have to have a
conversation with these mushrooms and to
be clear I was not ingesting the
mushrooms okay because I know who I'm
talking to
so I'm walking around and all of a
sudden I see in the ground the exact
same white long stringy mushrooms and
I'm like freaked out and I dropped to my
knees and I start crying and I said I'm
so sorry I'm so sorry what were you here
to teach me and they said the mushroom
said to me you're too afraid go into the
forest and find your place and now I'm
like freaking out even more so I just
standing up and I'm like stumbling
around and this is a time period in my
life where I'm just a freaking wreck and
I'm crying and I'm wandering through the
forest and I find this little sort of
indentation this little spot and I sit
down and I'm like sitting on my rump and
I've got my hands in my on my knees and
my head and I'm just crying and they
look up and often to my right is this
gorgeous spiderweb and it actually has
little dew drops glistening on it it was
like okay this they look like crystals
and this little spider comes walking out
it's this Virginia garden spider and I
look at it and I said okay I give up
what the [ __ ] are you here to teach me
because I have no idea and the spider
says to me you worry too much your
children are going to be fine
and I just start shaking because there's
no message that I needed to hear more
than that and so I came out of that
forest I came out of there at retreat
and a few weeks later was my 45th
birthday there about the actual year
doesn't matter so much as the fact that
it was my birthday and on my birthday I
got this spider tattoo
above my heart so that I can never
forget the fact that I worry too much
and that my kids are going to be alright
hmm so that's the spider has its has it
remained relevant to you is it something
that you consciously notice or because
it's so continuously present do you find
yourself sometimes losing sight of it
both meaning I'm often reminded as I was
when you asked and you said oh I'm gonna
ask you about the spider I'm often
reminded so thank you for reminding me
that that the point of that spiders
visitation to me was to Remember Who I
am
and I can use that reminder every day
because I forget every day not only did
I forget Who I am but I forget that my
kids are alright and that I worry too
much
hmm thank you for the story and you know
it makes me think of given the spider
Lakota mythology and ectomy their
various names for ectomy but it to me is
a spider trickster spirit bit of a hero
and perhaps one of the ways that you are
productive trickster is by asking
questions that are very uncomfortable or
they can be very uncomfortable and I
think that's one of your one of your
arts and we're gonna come back to that
for sure but I thought we could we could
revisit another perhaps chapter or event
in your life that seems to have been
very impactful could you talk to it was
February 2002 after something involving
the Olympics or the Olympic bid meeting
mmm
if you know what I'm referring to I am
so yeah so February 2002 I was working
at JPMorgan at the time I was Co leading
the technology investment practice for a
fund that was about twenty three billion
dollars under management so a large fund
and this was after having left Flatiron
partners in I think around the middle of
2001 and just for clarity that was
billion billions with Abby
that was billions with Abby yeah that's
a lot that's a large fund it's a large
fund I mean but we were very diversified
we did everything from Brazilian
railroads to you know funding the launch
of JetBlue airlines to you know the
latest web-based startup in some
capacity anyway and a few months prior
it had been cleared that my previous
fund flatiron partners needed to be
wound down and Fred and I needed to make
some decisions about what to do and I
was in the midst of trying to sort
through what I was going to do with the
rest of my life I I did not have the
internal capacity to raise a new fund I
know now that I was in the midst of a
very impression that exists was
exacerbated by the attacks of 9/11
and one of the ways I responded to the
attacks on 9/11 was to throw myself into
the Olympic bid effort we were bidding
to bring the 2012 games to New York and
for me this was a profoundly important
effort because now you're gonna make me
cry
my city was attacked
the city that I loved was the city where
I grew up the city of Brooklyn the place
that had so much meaning for me was
attacked be and and I remember the
feeling helpless during the fall
following the attack anyway around the
same time I had to decide whether or not
I was going to accept an offer to join
JPMorgan which had been one of the
funders and the funding partners for
flatiron partners and eventually I did
that and Fred linked up with Brad
Burnham and they launched Union Square
Ventures by the way worst decision of my
life but anyway to join JP Morgan and
not go to Union Square of interest
anyway so he went off and did that I
joined JP Morgan and by February 2002 I
was a wreck and what you're referring to
is February 2nd 2002 I left an Olympic
bid committee meeting which was being
held downtown not far from Ground Zero
and I found myself outside of the
stinking smoking hole that was the pile
as they referred to it of Ground Zero
and I remember feeling completely
overwhelmed and feeling like there were
ghosts flying around that area and I
wanted to die and I was obsessed with
the idea of running down to the Wall
Street subway station and leaping in
front of a subway and I ended up
deciding not to do that but wisely and
thankfully instead called my therapist
dr. sayers who said to me promptly get
in a cab and come out and see me and I
did just that
and saved my life at that point huh what
did your therapist do when you arrived
what was that session like can you
describe that session yeah
so dr. sayers is a psychoanalyst and so
I very traditionally almost like a New
York cartoon with lay on the couch and I
can't help but think of that and think
of like somehow it's a dog sitting in
that therapist right it's like it's some
sort of New Yorker thing anyway so I'm
laying on the couch staring up the
ceiling as I did all the time and I just
I remember saying to her just stick a
fork in me I'm [ __ ] done put me in
the hospital throw away the key
and you know to be clear the threat was
real because when I was 18 I did try to
kill myself and so you know no fooling
around here right I mean this isn't just
some idle ideation going on here this
was like I was in a I was in it I was 38
I was being cooked and I was declaring
that I was done and dr. sayers who was
also from Brooklyn said the most magical
thing possible she said what the hell do
you want to go to a hospital for the
food sucks go to Canyon Ranch you'll get
a massage every day you'll be so much
better well is what is Canyon Ranch
Canyon Ranch is a health spa and it's a
very nice place I loved it it was really
sweet but it's about as far removed from
a psychiatric hospital as you can
imagine because by the way I did spend
three months in a psychiatric hospital
so I sort of knew what I was getting
what I was asking for if you will so
that's what I did I made plans to go
down to Arizona I think it was the
Arizona branch of Canyon Ranch and
yeah that moved was the beginning of me
being rebuilt when and why did you spend
time in a psychiatric hospital well I
mentioned the suicide attempt right I
was 18 and I had on January 2nd
something about the number to write
January 2nd I guess it's 1981 I'm losing
track of the time I was I had just
turned 18 and I tried to kill myself I
cut my wrists and first went to I was
taken to the emergency room Jamaica
Hospital the Trump pavilion that's all
I'm gonna say and then I was transferred
from there to Creedmoor State Hospital
which is just this side of hell and then
from there after three days of Creedmoor
I was transferred to a hospital that
actually is no longer a hospital Cabrini
Medical Center in Manhattan where I was
there for three months
hmm I'd love to I think this is a good
point to come back to questions and good
questions and and you're very skilled in
this department so I'm gonna pose one of
your questions to you and you can feel
free to tweak it paraphrase it correct
it any way you like but if you look back
to 2002 mmm
how were you complicit in creating the
conditions in your life that you would
have said you didn't want
ah nice turn which is a great question
so maybe you could repeat it for folks
because it is so important and this is
something that has currently aided me
when you introduced it to me many moons
ago
and then if you could speak to that as
it applies to that particular period in
your life yeah yeah so I'll unpack the
question so the way I usually ask the
question goes like this how have I been
complicit in creating the conditions I
say I don't want and the reason for the
language is very very careful it's very
purposeful I like to use the word
complicit and not responsible 90% of the
time when I first asked that question
people hear the word how have I been
responsible for the conditions complicit
Ness is important because it's not it's
a levy
it's a relieving the person from the
burden of feeling responsible for all
the [ __ ] in their lives because that's
not fair to carry that responsibility
but it's helpful to think of ourselves
as somehow being served by the complete
the challenges that we're going through
the second piece of that is that I say I
don't want and that sort of unpacks that
notion even further which is there's
something oftentimes about the way in
which we operate and the way we set up
the conditions of our lives to be in in
unconscious service to us the
psychological term is secondary gain but
there are there are ways in which we
find ourselves repeating patterns in our
life we always date the same type of
person we are always finding ourselves
in the same kind of job we're always
frustrated by the same sorts of
situation and so it's really useful to
sort of start to unpack that so that's
that question and before I even answer
your question I want to say one other
thing the discomfort of difficult and
powerful questions reminds me of
something my daughter Emma likes to say
about me which is that he imagine
growing up with a man who asks you
questions that you really rather not
answer
[Laughter]
so shout out to Emma so I think that the
way I was complicit I guess we should
thank Emma for being the crash-test
dummy for the questions that you use now
in your career you got what happened to
Michael Mike Emma and her brothers
Michael and Sam for sure for sure God
loved them they put up with so much with
me oh my god dad stop coaching me so
yeah so before I can answer that
question
honestly what I would say is dr. sayers
taught me three additional questions and
those questions are what am I not saying
that needs to be said
what am I saying that's not being heard
and what's being said that I'm not
hearing
hmm so again what am I not saying that
needs to be said what am I saying that's
not being heard and what's being said
that I'm not hearing and so for me the
way I was complicit was I wasn't
speaking I wasn't saying what I needed
to say and more often than not Tim the
suffering that I encounter can almost
always be routed back to somebody not
saying something that needs to be said
and if there's a little correlate to
that and not saying it or not saying it
in a way that it can be heard because
oftentimes we speak without words but by
our actions and we go unheard could you
give an example of something that you
needed to say during that period of time
that you didn't
wasn't hurt yeah yeah something very
very simple I wasn't happy that despite
all the outward trappings of success I
was empty and hollow inside that I
wasn't speaking truthfully that I wasn't
living in integrity and that I was too
afraid of losing the good graces and
esteem of everybody around me to
actually talk about the fact that I did
not want to do what I was doing with my
life at that point oh by the way I
didn't know what else I was going to do
but that's a separate issue right mm-hmm
I mean I knew when I decided not to
continue working with Fred Wilson stupid
man that I was I knew that it was
actually the right thing for me to do
but when I agreed to take a job at
JPMorgan it wasn't because I wanted to
continue doing that work it's because I
was too terrified to do anything other
than that and I certainly didn't want to
lose the esteem and the good wishes I
mean think about your reaction just a
few minutes ago when you pointed out
that it was a twenty three billion
dollar fund and even in that moment I
felt a little bit of that pride mixed
with a little bit of the shame because I
walked away from that hmm right
and I didn't want to lean into that
space of like what if I don't matter
anymore
what if nobody calls me how did you get
over them what are the things that
contributed to you making it through
those questions because a lot of people
seemingly don't make it through those
questions right they stay in a guy stuck
in a given relationship they stay stuck
exactly for 5 10 15 20 or more years so
what a life lifetime when we love him
what did emerson say the vast majority
of men
let's update it the vast majority of
people lead lives of quiet desperation
so you know I how did I get out of it I
guess your question implies an agency
that I didn't feel at the time meaning
huh I wake up one day and I decide I'm
going to you know be different no it
wasn't that it was it was that I ran out
of the ability to continue to operate
anymore it was that moment above the lip
of ground zero and that moment where I
chose not to leap in front of the subway
but to get into the cab and go to see
dr. sayers and it was that moment where
I decided to follow her advice and go to
Canyon Ranch and it was that it was the
series of moments where it was like okay
I know it's not working I admit it's not
working I don't know what I'm going to
do but what I have been doing hurts too
much and if I have to deal if I have to
suffer the consequence of the loss of
status approbation affirmation all the
external trappings so be it
it was like my soul basically said
listen [ __ ] you better sit down
and pay attention to your life because
the stakes are too high I think I read
that in the bhagavad-gita from correct
[Laughter]
now how did you find your way to I'll
use this term it may not be the best
term but how did you find your way to
coaching so on that plane ride from New
York to Arizona to Canyon Ranch I read
three books when things fall apart by
Ani Pema Chodron faith by Sharon
Salzberg and let your life speak by
Parker Palmer and before fully answering
your question I'll give you this I must
have done something really really good
in a past life because I have the
benefit of considering all three of
those people Ani Pema Sharon Salzberg
and Parker Palmer as my friends I didn't
know them at the time but I have the
good grace and the incredible good
fortune to say I I'm friends with them
they are my teachers so what was your
question the question was how did you
find your way to coaching and just to
reiterate something that you just said
at the time they were not your friends
that's right but you had the books and
so on and how you found your way to
coach it and you you you you went back
to the plane ride right and so in
reading those books and those those
three books were really important
because they did lead indirectly to me
becoming a coach each one of those books
presented something different to me
faith presented this notion of really
being honest with myself was what was
going on when things fall apart was the
first laying out of Buddhist Dharma as a
path but it was let your life speak
which is a brilliant beautiful short
little collection of essays that really
shifted to dialogue for me
partially because Parker is so open and
honest and authentic about his own
struggles and depression okay so to your
question let me fast-forward it probably
four or five years later I'm I'm still
working my way through all the issues
that I'm I'm carrying at that point in
trying to sort myself out I'm in an
office I'm sharing office space with
Fred Wilson and Brad Burnham from Union
Square Ventures but I have a little sub
office within their space and I'm doing
a bunch of different things I'm serving
on a bunch of boards of directors I'm
making little angel investments here and
there but I'm just sort of hanging
around the hoop if you will and this
young guy comes to see me and he says
he's there to quote Network you know
this is the thing everybody is supposed
to do Network his way to a new new job
and you know you ask about questions so
here's the story so he comes in and he's
a lawyer and he wants to get a job in
the startup industry so he wants to find
a way to get some sort of position and I
turned to him and he's probably in his
late 20s and I said I'm happy to help
you but just answer a question for me
it's kind of my first coaching question
right and I said what made you to become
a lawyer in the first place and he
starts crying to me and he starts
telling me about pleasing his father and
about how it was you know his father had
taught him that if all else fails at
least he could make a living as a lawyer
and the and the kid was just miserable
just miserable and so I reached up to
the shelf and I pulled down a copy of
let your life speak and I said here read
this and they get back to me and then I
he left the office and I turned around
and I said [ __ ] I think I need to be a
coach mm-hmm I need to do that more
frequently and so within a few days I'd
signed up for a coach training program
okay let me pause for one second so what
did you feel what did you experience
what was it about that encounter that
made you so decisively say that to
yourself a couple of things I could see
relief in his eyes I could see I think I
think the first thing I felt was empathy
I knew his feelings because even though
the content of the story was different
my experience were so similar I had been
so ruled by fears that I was living in a
box I had lived in a box that was not of
my making it was somebody else's box it
was the wrong box
there's the wrong suit of clothes it was
not me
and I could feel all that and when I
reach for let your life speak I was
reaching for the very same thing that
had gotten me out of the box and I said
here here's a path and there was just
relief relief not that he had read the
book yet but just relieved that somebody
actually understood his feelings and had
given words to his feelings that he
hadn't been able to give to remember
that question what have I not been
saying that I need to say there was that
going on for him so then I said wait a
minute dude you can do something about
relieving suffering
you're not the mess and it's not always
just your prefrontal cortex that's gonna
figure everything out because I didn't
have any answer for him I didn't say
here here's the job you should do that's
perfect for you so that you no longer go
to bed at night feeling like crap
wondering whether or not you should wake
up in the morning I just had to listen
to my heart and I did something
completely non-intuitive I reached onto
my bookshelf and I gave him a book and
feeling that I had was poignant pain
coupled with a sense of being able to do
something I could be helpful you know
this this may be overreaching but how
much of your call to coaching do you
think if any was finding relief and
taking the focus outside of yourself oh
my god what a great question
Minh to begin coaching this helps me
every day I mean this is the craziness
about the work that I do about living my
my vocation like this even today in my
worst moments when I can be with another
person's pain by the way which is the
root ideological meaning of the word
compassion to be with someone else's
feelings I magically feel relief from my
own unbearable feelings because I think
I think that's the essence of being
human together we get to actually oh
geez we look at each other across the
the campfire I keep imagining us and
sort of pre civilization going like
looking across the campfire and again
must be in Brooklyn a gun dang it's hard
right isn't it hard being human yeah
it's really hard okay let's do this
together
so I think the call was that but if I if
I may I think the call was also too
retro actively go back in time and save
myself interesting see this this makes a
lot of sense to me in saying that do you
mean and I don't know if you've ever
heard of ifs and it's internal family
systems in this in so much as you by by
helping people who are in similar
positions with similar
sir pains as you experienced earlier you
are healing that younger version of
yourself in it's a necessity you know
yeah well first of all to answer your
quick question I have heard of ifs I
have not been trained in ifs and I know
a few a few my clients have benefited
from it
but broadly speaking you want to
understand Buddhism it's what we're
talking about right now yeah you want to
understand wisdom traditions across the
world it's what we're talking about
right now
it's like you know even the best of
Christianity even the best of what Jesus
taught it's like God I mean I just
imagine him exasperated sitting missing
for God's sake love one another just you
know come on can you just stop the
nonsense and just reach across and just
be with each other and that and that
there's a cut think of it this way Tim
there's almost like a universal
wellspring of pain that you and I share
and in the similar fashion there's a
universal wellspring of happiness and
joy that you and I share and so if
you're in this painful spot I can tap
that universal wellspring of happiness
and joy and pointed a little bit more at
your suffering and you can do the same
for me so let me ask you a question and
you and I have spent a good amount of
time on the phone together and to those
people listening who are self-described
high achievers who don't want to lose
their edge who are looking for the
tactical practical if they hear that and
they're kind of rolling their eyes and
they're like alright you had me at 9/11
you had me at the books but I don't see
how this applies I'm too busy for that
[ __ ] I don't have time to go to Burning
Man and do fire dancing like this this
is serious business I have serious work
to do
sorry how do you relate that to someone
who in their first meeting
is fits that profile perhaps what do you
do yeah what do you do with them in a
first meeting yeah so my job isn't to
necessarily convince people that they
need help right right and so the first
thing I say is and the first thing I
would say to anybody who's listening is
if everything is working for you
go at it have a great time go enjoy
yourself go ahead but you know there's a
there's a simple little trick you know I
have this little reputation that I make
people cry and all this stuff you know
what I do I ask them a simple question
how are you and I often follow it up
with like no really don't [ __ ] me
how are you how are you really feeling
because here's the thing you describe
the this would be resistant person as a
high achiever here's the thing about
high achievers in my experience high
achievers early on in their life figure
out how to get in a they figure it out
because the whole system is geared
towards that great and then we take that
entire system from our childhood and we
move it into work and it's just getting
a is getting a is getting a is getting
a's and the highest achieving people
oftentimes come in to me scared because
there's a little whisper voice in their
ear that says you are a [ __ ] fraud
you have no idea and when they figure
out that all you're doing is reading the
tea leaves and what it takes to get an A
they're gonna toss you out of the tribe
they're gonna toss you out on your ass
they're gonna push you away or they say
to themselves because they haven't
experienced loss or they haven't
experienced failure they think they
haven't experienced failure
they're just waiting they're just
playing a waiting game they're just
waiting for something for fate to catch
up to them and bang the Hammers going to
come down now if this resonates with you
you might also then recognize the
anxiety that comes in where you put your
head down at the pillow at then at night
and you go my god I don't know if I can
do it again tomorrow
maybe they'll catch me tomorrow and if
that's what you're working with
then there's an opportunity in all that
we're talking about forget Universal
suffering forget about Wellsprings
forget about spiders forget about
Burning Man which I've never been to by
the way and I don't believe in
substances but that's a whole new for a
nation forget about all that stuff
I've been three times I I'm a fan at
least once in your lifetime but we
separate conversation so continuous god
the truth is are probably too scared to
ingest any material inside of my body
but leave that aside for a moment I
forget all that okay all the esoteric
stuff like that here's the simple
question how is it working for you
because if it's not working for you why
are you in pain
why are you doing it and would you like
a little release and here you want to
know the secret like nasty little trick
that I play yes I get them if they
either have children or hope to have
children someday I will ask them what
would they like their children to feel
when they're at the same age because if
they would like them to feel something
other than what they're feeling now is
the time to start changing the way they
organize their lives that's a really
good question what if and this could
combine with what we're talking about
right now someone comes in they don't
feel impostor syndrome necessarily
but they are simply overwhelmed you ask
them how they are no really and they're
like I'm good I'm just busy I'm stressed
I just have too much I'm overwhelmed if
that's the breed of client that shows up
how do you begin to work with that
well once you've established a certain
level of trust and relating through
empathy and you know don't necessarily
try to step in and fix it
the first question I would start to ask
or elicit is how is that being busy
serving you remember that how have I
been complicit in creating the
conditions I say I don't want right
because here's here's the thing about
busyness busyness can feel [ __ ]
awesome it can feel so amazing
internally I can look at all the great
stuff I got done externally look at how
busy I am I must be important that's an
interesting statement busyness can also
feel can also serve to to distract you
from those voices inside that say hey
I'm not happy hey I'm not happy hey I'm
serious I'm going to throw you down on
the ground with some sort of somatic
illness lower back problem irritable
bowel syndrome migraine headaches that
was my specialty I'm gonna throw you
down until you pay attention to me
okay you're too busy okay I got you okay
because you know here's the thing -
somewhere around 35 to 50 years old the
system's start to break down the systems
that got you add a childhood that got
you into adulthood that got you
established that got you to the point
where you think he got it all figured
out and then all of a sudden holy [ __ ]
the whole thing starts to collapse now
what do I do and when I see someone
who's busy who
kind of in the early 20s I see a striver
trying to establish themselves but when
I see somebody who's busy who actually
doesn't need to be that way
I get really really curious what
internal need is trying to be met by all
that busyness and that's the place to to
inquire what are some of the what are
the most some of the more common
patterns that you see with that busyness
I'm very curious about this well I I
promise not to coach you but why is it
so curious it no just kidding I can tell
you no I can tell you I can tell you why
it's curious or interesting to man yeah
we can pick it we can jump into some I'm
game I'm game to I'm game to hit some
volleys if you want well for instance
I'm looking at an apologies to everyone
I have not replied to but that is sort
of my ethos and the gist of everything
I've written so I feel like I've bought
some permission but I currently have six
hundred and eighteen thousand nine
hundred and fifty two unread email and a
combination on two different tracks of
165 plus 250 500 text messages and
that's that's the tip of the iceberg so
I actually feel surprisingly low anxiety
about that nonetheless a small amount of
anxiety and in the process of literally
rebooting those various phone numbers
and addresses because it's not
physically possible to address that
right and it's it's perhaps similar to
many of your experiences it's given me a
an opening line or common sentiment of
commiseration that opens up the
floodgates to similar types of problems
in other people so they confess I'm like
the the productivity guy in the
confessional box for people
want to tell me about similar things
yeah and that is that is those are a few
things that come to mind when you ask me
why is that curious and I think I think
it's very common I just think it's very
good I think it's hugely common and I
think that you know you it you ask the
question by using a particular
descriptive word you described it as
feeling overwhelmed right and you know
if we were to do dream analysis we might
talk about being flooded that's
typically the the psychological signal
that the system is over overwhelmed so
again we use our we use our construction
and we talked about complicit in is not
necessarily responsibility right so and
I'm gonna I'm gonna use you as an
example as a high achiever who is
incredibly busy and so busy that he has
over 600,000 unanswered emails and we'll
just stick on that one for a moment by
the way you're allowed to declare
bankruptcy at that point okay you're
done oh yeah and what I hear you say is
I no longer you said I don't feel
anxiety just a small piece of it I that
you probably have have been so
overwhelmed by it that you've actually
given up feeling anxious about it and
it's just like forget I'm not gonna get
to it right so here's the question for
you and you don't have to answer it but
but hang out with it a couple questions
the first would might be something like
when did you start feeling overwhelmed
and how long have you felt overwhelmed
and while feeling overwhelmed did you
take on more tasks right in your case
Tim did you sign up for another book in
another show or another thing which only
produce more stuff
because that's what I do right if
there's a tiny bit of open space in my
life I tend to fill it right and so you
know and then the magical question is
how does that how familiar is that
feeling and how does that feeling serve
you hmm
I'm willing to I'm willing to to play on
this one and I will say before I get
started that I do think I have much
better systems and rules and
perspectives in place now but I but to
answer your questions I'd say it started
probably middle of undergraduate college
Rises this feeling of overwhelm and or
at least that's when it was most
noticeable and the feeling of overwhelm
was then kind of ebb and flow day up
until at least 2004 my solution to
feeling anything I didn't want to feel
was to add more activities just a pause
and say that again mm-hmm your solution
to feeling anything I didn't want to
feel in retrospect I recognized that's
what it was so if I felt anything I
didn't want to feel I would add more
activities to drown it out some people
use heroin some people use coke some
people use work and I used activities at
the time I also use stimulants so I was
in fact using both but that changed
quite a bit in 2004 by building in empty
space and I think that still now there
are vestiges of behaviors that in some
sense helped me to find a toehold in
financial security that are no longer
serving me that are nonetheless default
gears if that makes sense sure and to
that extent the vast amount of my focus
for the law
year has been on saying no to
practically everything more than more
than a year I mean the last several
years nonetheless there is a part of me
I think you had a was it crow or Raven
on the shoulder okay who will come back
to the crow and know it's not another
dream sequence for people wondering no
drug-induced dream thing will come back
to the crow something on my shoulder
saying it you might need this person you
might eat this for this person in
reference to any given email that might
come in and so for what I what I find in
my life is that the vast majority of
stuff is clearly noise and I can ignore
there are categories of activities I'm
not particularly good at moderation
whether that's with yeah you know sex
chips or chocolate or speaking
engagements or fill in the blank there's
certain things where I need to either be
considering each each item that presents
itself or not consider them at all as a
category and so I've decided certain
things just from a binary perspective
like speaking I will not do any of
unless they happen to be ten minute
drive from my house and fit twenty other
parameters otherwise it's an automatic
no and I don't even see it where I where
I think I find more difficulty is where
there are people who have been very
helpful in the past who perhaps were
very supportive in their early days
who now have lots of favors to ask and
that is that but if I'm listening to my
body
it's it's absolutely not a full body yes
there is part of me there's a large part
of me that knows I do not want to
acquiesce I do not want to agree I do
not want to accept I do not want to
whatever it is they're asking me to do
because it doesn't feel right and or
it's unreasonable nonetheless those are
the types of emails that tend to pile up
and those are the types of emails also
that even if I have someone like an
assistant or multiple assistants
filtering the names are probably
probably noticeable enough or old enough
that they'll get brought to my attention
so let's see here
is it familiar yes familiar how does it
serve me this I have more trouble with
so maybe you could walk me through I
would imagine many people I'm not gonna
say it doesn't serve me because I'm
willing to at least as a thought
exercise to accept that if it didn't
serve me out I would have already found
some clean solution or I wouldn't have
any emotional difficulty fixing it
how would you walk me through figuring
out how it serves me yeah so the first
thing I did I want to reflect back a
couple of things that I'm hearing so
that we can just sort of establish it
the first thing I would say is I really
admire all the filtering that you've put
into your life and the structures that
you've put into your life to create
boundaries and saying no and that and
and I think that the rules as you define
them and they might be rules for like
hey every morning I'm going to do X and
every afternoon I'm going to do Y or I'm
only going to work from hours those are
all important but ultimately
insufficient for complete relief from
some of these feelings they're really
really helpful they've reduced your
anxiety from overwhelming to small but
six hundred and twenty thousand emails
right and so I want to bring your
attention to two other feelings one was
you said something about missing
something that might be important to you
seeing someone that
has been helpful to you in the past or
something that's important to you that
you might miss something so that's one
fear is that right I I would say so I
think the greater fear is that people
who would at least believe that they
have supported me without asking for a
quid pro quo in the past would get upset
and this does happen it has happened
where people take things very personally
and I recognize I can't take
responsibility for everyone else's
feelings and responses to things I do
think that's a fear more than missing an
opportunity because I'm not concerned
about missing financial opportunities
not anymore
not not anymore I once was but I also
see I stopped startup investing
completely in 2015 because the noise
simply wasn't worth it the cortisol
fueled unnecessary hurrying associated
with that culture was causing more harm
than good so I stopped in 2015 so I
missed a pretty pretty decent bull run
which I'm okay with so it's not a
financial concern so much as a social
cost well and fall out if that makes
sense yeah yeah what I'm hearing is a
fear of disappointing someone who
matters to you
yeah yeah that would be a piece of it
there'll be a piece of it and this is
helpful to me to talk through because
it's not just disappointment in some
cases I can't
I actually really dislike interacting
with some of these more recent
acquaintances but for whatever reason
they view their position is very
entitled in so much as they expect a
fast and very compliant response for me
on many things and they know a lot of
people in the same circles and so that
causes concern so there's an implicit
internal existential threat I think
that's fair I think it's fair to say and
yeah if I could say one more thing yeah
yeah yeah just just so I don't sound
totally like I'm living in a land of
make-believe I have run into many many
instances this is you know more than a
dozen at least where say someone will
send me an email they want a blurb for a
new book they want this this this this
this and this and by the way it's coming
on in four weeks or whatever it is
there's some set of requests slash
demands
I don't reply this has happened with
journalists as well where for whatever
reason I won't help them and then a hit
piece comes out or then there's some
type of blowback slash kind of vengeful
behavior whether that's shit-talking me
on stage or whatever might be so there
there are stairs evidence to support the
fear but Here I am I've survived I'm
fine
that is also true so I just went right
to add that color right and so I want to
reflect back to you empathetically and
and rationally you're not nuts right
these threats are real at least not at
least not in that department that's
right
that's right so what I often say is that
there are three basic risks that we're
all trying to manage all the time
love safety and belonging we want to
love and be loved we want to feel safe
physically emotionally spiritually and
we want to feel that we belong and what
I'm hearing well so if you resonate with
those at all the the existential threat
and I want to bring your attention to
existential because I think that the
threat is to the essence of who you are
or at least the perceived threat and and
what's own trash-talks you onstage you
know whether with the trash talking
is you write the the you not not the
meat bag but the essence of you and so I
think that the fear I know for myself
that the fear of disappointing others is
a threat to my belonging I'm not going
to be my family anymore my children
won't love me my partners won't love me
and so therefore I will be unsafe I will
be bereft I'll be by myself I'll be
alone in the woods fending for myself
and there are a few things that threaten
me more than the threat to belonging I
don't know does that resonate with you
it does resonate uh I think that a lot
of what I've done and been able to do
has been dependent on maintaining very
long term relationships with people who
I enjoy being friends with who happened
to also be very very good at what they
did whatever that is and so I think
there's a bit of you know what got you
here won't get you where you want to go
or won't get you there and that does
resonate I and we don't have to jump to
this but what I'd love to talk about or
eat or listen to you describe because I
think a lot of people would benefit from
it is when you run into someone who like
me is fielding a lot of impound and it
could be from one person but they for
whatever reason are having difficulty
saying no or establishing boundaries
what are tools or books or approaches
that you found helpful for people in
that position whether it's nonviolent
communication or fill-in-the-blank
anything at all or questions anything at
all
how do you begin to advise someone like
that well there's a couple of things
come to mind and I'm gonna reference two
friends of ours Seth Godin in Sharon
Salzberg the first thing was when I was
really struggling with this early on in
my career my adult career as Seth Godin
gave me some wonderful advice which
which boiled down to this phrase I wish
I could but I can't and that became a
kind of interesting little fence around
my life a boundary marker the problem
was that it ran out of so and so the
idea was that you would you would be
able to say to someone someone who
reaches out can you do this favor for me
this thing for me and you get to say I
wish I could but I can't so you just
sort of pause around that the problem is
of course there's an inauthentic that
can set in which is I actually don't
wish I can but I won't write and so then
it becomes a little bit of like you know
listen I'm trying to take my own advice
to heart and the advice I give clients
is to take care of themselves first
right and so that becomes a kind of
useful tool but then you reference
something before about not being
responsible for someone else's feelings
and and that brought to mind a teaching
that Sharon Salzberg gave me which was
which goes like this all beings own
their own karma their happiness or
unhappiness depend upon their actions
not my wishes for them say that one more
time please yeah so all beings own their
own karma karma being the cause and
effect the act there were consequences
of their actions mm-hmm their happiness
or unhappiness depend upon their actions
not my wishes for them or the corollary
to that is not the actions that I take
or don't take now they may say to you
when they're reaching out to you Tim Tim
if you don't do this thing that I'm
asking you to do then I will be unhappy
and if I'm unhappy I will be mean to you
I mean that's essentially the the
existential threat I wish they would
actually just send that email because
then I would say gotcha gotcha [ __ ] I
have a blog shouldn't have sent that
email which is actually happened with
writers from the New York Times believe
it or not their threat oh yeah and then
as soon as they realize what they've
done they're like ah [ __ ] and then they
cool jets but yeah so here's a little
tool that I that I have come up with
that helps me as I often think of like
creating these little fences and I often
visualize a chain-link fence so that I
can see through it and it has a gate in
it and the gate only opens one way
inward and I get to control whether or
not the gate opens and so then I can see
someone on the other side and then the
phrase that comes up is love them from
afar be kind to them in my heart set
clear boundaries right I have you know
as your friend as your guide as somebody
hopefully as to any shoulder to shoulder
with you is sort of in this crazy
journey
I really feel free for all the people
who have reached out to you six hundred
twenty thousand times and your inbox and
all of that stuff and I feel for you and
I would advise you to delete every one
of those things and to basically love
all of those people who are gonna get
unanswered from afar and be kind to them
in your heart and recognize that on the
whole you're doing the best that you can
because you are you know I I wish I
could give you like here here's the tool
you know like NBC nonviolent
communications has some brilliant tools
or or here's the book that magically
unlocks that to me the challenge isn't
not having the tool the challenge is in
this meaning that we put into the
situation that is the hardest thing to
come over and to recognize that you're
okay even if you're not necessarily
being yet your kindness or at your best
because like you like everybody else
like me we all get resources that are
thin at times my god oh my god
and so you know if you've not answered a
text message for me Tim or if you've not
answered an email from me I am never
ever ever gonna think ill of you well I
appreciate that and I wish I could
transmit that composure to all of my
620,000 senders let me ask you a
situational question and this is this is
true in my life and I'm sure it's true
for many people listening that I have a
handful of people who are kind of close
to me very much in the same circles
playing at a high level who tend to
reach out to me only when there is an
ask of some type and there tends to be
some great degree of discomfort
associated with the ask it in so much as
perhaps they have two or three people
who are close friends of mine attending
an event of theirs or investing in
blabbity blah whatever might be so that
it is there's a there's a great degree
of discomfort that I feel in ignoring
the email maybe I actually get texted by
one friend and then the email from this
person there are a few people who are
repeat characters kind of like Newman
and Seinfeld and Sunday so I have I have
at least a half a dozen Newman's who are
pretty tough to get rid of
and they're not very good at reading
hints or they deliberately ignore hints
that I don't want to do things that I
don't want to respond have you coached
people through breaking up with friends
or having direct conversations with
their own newman's and then maybe the
Newman is a co-founder maybe the Newman
is a someone on the board of directors
maybe fill in the blank for having a
really direct conversation about this
type of dynamic sure
can we put aside just for a moment
co-founder and board member because they
totally do there are power dynamics
there that are different than the
Newman's that you've been talking about
yeah let's leave out co-founder and
board member I agree that adds
complexity or we can circle back to it
separately but but but here's the thing
if we start with a basic basic basic
basic premise it goes like this am i a
good person
am i doing the best that I can and if I
can answer that question relatively
straightforwardly and honestly then I
don't have to feel guilty because that's
what we're talking about right that's
the emotion that gets manipulated I
don't have to feel guilty saying to
somebody I don't have the space to do
the thing that you would like me to do
which might include maintaining this
contact and there's an image that I
often use whether it's with a client or
with my own self and that is and it's
come to me as I've gotten older and I'm
obsessed right now with Mead myself
being old and the images of a bonsai
tree which over its lifetime you know
you can see this you know one foot tall
bonsai tree and it could be anywhere
from 10 years old to 300 years old and
you have really no idea right and what I
see is something that has been carefully
pruned
into a thing of beauty and I think that
that's our opportunity in life
if we start with the supposition that we
are never enough that we are not good
enough and that we therefore not only
you said before become addicted to
busyness in order to make ourselves not
feel the things that we don't want to
feel remember that well one of the
things that we do is we maintain
unhealthy relationships in order to not
feel the things that we don't want to
feel even when those unhealthy
relationships make us feel other things
we don't want to feel whereas if we
start with the basic premise that we are
enough just as we are and that there is
no great loss to you Tim if over time
you lose some connection and you use
this term several times to some
high-powered person oh my goodness this
high achieving person this high
performer person there's no real great
loss if like think of the people that
you have interviewed over the years the
people that you know for whom who maybe
maybe began in some powerful position
and that have gone on to some powerful
position oh my god if I lose that
connection that I once had to them then
somehow I'm at a loss you take a breath
we breathe into that the Buddha taught
us one thing you are basically good just
as you are not because of the
connections that you have maintained and
those people who love you and care about
you and understand the essence are going
to be fine even if you say hey I'm sorry
I actually can't maintain this
connection may I ask you a question sure
all right
so I agree with everything you just said
and what I'd love to hear you elaborate
on is any practices or tools that you
use or recommend people use to get from
intellectually agreeing with what you
just said
to embodying that in some way that
translates to different behavior does
that make sense because I mean one of my
favorite quotes is I guess it's Ted
Geisel but dr. Seuss which is the people
who matter don't mind and the people who
mind don't matter I mean I love that
quote I remind myself at self of it all
the time nonetheless I do have this
guilt that crops up on occasion that I
recognizes counterproductive nonetheless
it crops up and causes me to behave in
ways that I know are not necessary nor
productive and I'm wondering how you
help people to make that leap from kind
of the intellectual uh-huh yep I get it
to the other lily pad of behavioral
change well the first thing I would say
is that the practice that you just
described embodying the Ted guy's little
dr. Seuss quote that is a practice and
the first thing to do is to remember
that the thing about the word practices
that we actually never achieve right
we're always moving towards we're always
going there but oftentimes achieving it
permanently sustained persistently yeah
that's a tough one so in those moments
when we fail to understand and remember
that those of us who those who love us
won't mind when we fail to remember that
it can be helpful to remember what I was
saying before about I am enough and I'm
doing the best that I can or as dr.
sayers ones taught me not bad
considering not bad considering how
rough you may have had it not bad
considering how hard your life is right
now you're okay you're okay
and if I can say that to myself every
day in one form or another bringing a
kind of mindful attention to the points
when I fail with a kind of forgiveness
to myself
well then Wow okay that can be helpful
do you use journaling for this
I know journaling is very important to
you and I want to discuss that as a
topic and yeah there are a million in
one ways to journals I'd like to learn
more about how you use journaling but is
is journaling one of the ways you remind
yourselves of these things yes yes and
if so what does it look like it down
down to the mundane details do you write
down I am enough as a prompt and then
write for two paragraphs on why that is
the case or how does how does one
implement this yeah yeah yeah thank you
so just for context I have been
journaling consistently since there was
about 13 years old
daily and I'm 55 so a hell of a lot of
journals and again to be consistent and
I think you do the same thing i
handwrite I do you know and what may be
unusual is I never go back and reread
because it's not about figuring [ __ ] out
it's about the experience and so my
general prompt the thing I almost always
start with is right now I'm feeling and
I simply bring my attention to it and so
I might be feeling to talk about this
very specific situation guilt right so
for example and I'll use this sort of
mindful attention if I were to journal
about our conversation one of the things
I might journal is about the guilt that
I have felt over the years as to whether
or not I was reaching out to you when
you might be in trouble or if I was one
of those folks who put you in an
uncomfortable situation and I bring that
up not to elicit a response from you but
as an example of an exploration of the
guilty feelings that I might have where
are they coming from what are they doing
was I kind that sort of thing
and then I blow a kiss to myself easy
there buddy boy easy
this is all a journaling exercise I'm
just talking it out and I remember
something that's really important about
that word guilt guilt is self focused
remorse is about the other remorse is oh
I hurt someone's feelings and I would
like to not be hurtful so I'm going to
try not to be hurtful guilt is oh my god
I can't believe this I'm ruminating
ruminating ruminating ruminating and if
I find myself journaling in a ruminating
kind of way I try to bring attention to
that and that's the moment where I say
easy boy easy
you're a good man because sometimes
fails to live up to your aspirations
that's it that's simple I also promised
I would return to the crow this might be
a good place uh-huh yeah now I'm gonna
get the pronunciation wrong Mary help me
with the last name
peel and pancit Pollux yeah and it's
Murray Murray Murray ways it's always a
tricky one alright summary pancit pancit
and still with us thank God and the crow
what is what does she yeah with the show
boy described in terms of the crow this
that might fit might not but I want to
make sure I fulfill my promise to her Oh
does it I think it does fit so Murray
was one of my professors in college she
taught poetry but I also took a took a
particular track in teaching writing and
so she was also my mentor and she used
to talk all the time about the crow who
sits on your shoulder telling you what a
piece of [ __ ] you are that's a piece of
[ __ ] I can't believe you wrote that you
know it's like I hear that voice and it
sits on your shoulder and it tells you
all the things that you have done wrong
and
all the things that is happening and
often times in my journal sometimes I'll
take a second pen so that there are two
different colors I will allow the crow
to speak this is really important this
isn't it a jujitsu move because the
mistake I think a lot of people make is
they try this for rocks at the crow and
shut the crow up right and that crow is
a really interesting voice that crow
tells us all the things that we are
doing wrong and the ways in which we are
not enough and that's the linkage back
to what we were just talking about this
notion that we are not enough just by
our self that's the fuel by which the
crow is there now this is the move to
make the crows mission is to preserve
your ability to be loved to feel safe
and that you belong what it makes you
feel like [ __ ] though yes it makes you
feel like [ __ ] but it's motivation is
for you not to feel ashamed and so the
crow is doing you a favor the crow is
trying to keep you safe the problem is
the crow is so attentive and so vigilant
that's a little too active and so what
we want to say at that moment is thanks
a lot buddy I really appreciate it but
all those people who might be angry with
me because I didn't respond to them or
do the thing they wanted me to do they
actually don't really see me and if they
don't see me they don't know that I'm
doing the best that I can so I'll blow
my kiss I'll put them on the other side
of that chain-link fence and I'll love
them from afar yeah this is this is
really important and by this I mean
everything that we've been talking about
pretty much since the get-go but
especially I'm referring to the
journaling and
creating an outlet for the crow or the
monkey mind or what Tim urban of wait
but why would call the mammoth and I
highly recommend that everybody check
out an article he wrote called taming
the mammoth which is on this subject
that if you hate that part of yourself
and try to contain it at least in my
experience that does nothing but
exacerbate it does nothing but worsen
the problem but along the lines of say
morning pages you know Julia Cameron and
so on writing free end in the morning
and providing that monkey mind an
opportunity to fix itself on paper at
least for me gives me a tremendous
amount of increased levity during the
day it removes a huge burden do you tend
to journal first thing upon waking up
could you walk us through when you're at
your best what is your first when do you
wake up what is your first kind of 60 to
90 minutes look like over two hours
whatever you choose yeah it's uh it's
two hours and when I'm at my best I wake
I clean up so a shower and stuff like
that and I have caffeine because you do
not want to be around me without
caffeine what time do you wake up
generally between 5:00 and 6:00 almost
without fail usually without without an
alarm clock so I'm really awful at
around 9 o'clock at night I'm a very
boring person I do not look at my phone
let me say that again I do not look at
my phone I do not look at my phone
because it's just too painful and with a
cup of coffee coffee not coffee as I say
from Brooklyn and then I journal usually
for an hour
and then I sit in meditation usually for
an hour a half-hour or sometimes 45
minutes it sort of depends on how the
day is going and what's going on but the
entire period feels like one quiet
meditative period so that's me at my
best
the journaling for an hour let's I
wanted to dig into that a bit because I
think it's such a powerful tool and I'd
like to hear more about how that hour is
spent so I'm looking at a page in the
new book mmm appropriately named reboot
and you have in this book different
journaling invitations rights so you
might have let's give a few examples in
what ways do I deplete myself and run
myself into the ground where am i where
am i running from and where to
why have I allowed myself to be so
exhausted you mentioned earlier that you
often start the journaling with right
now I'm feeling dot dot dot are there
other prompts that you personally tend
to use more than others why we'd never
say that I would use prompts like I'm
going to use the same prompt every time
usually the one thing that I do
consistently is right now I'm feeling
and then generally speaking I might
review the the path 24 hours almost in a
diary kind of fashion you know so
yesterday I woke up and then I also
don't worry about explaining people so I
might say and then I met with Mary Jane
and I don't have to explain who Mary
Jane is because who cares I'm never
gonna read it again and nobody is ever
gonna read it right so I don't I get rid
of all that monkey mind [ __ ] chatter
right and I just go right into it and I
presume that the journal knows all sees
all has been there with me all along
that's an important point secondarily I
will ask myself many questions like how
long have I felt this way which will
then bring me back to some early
memories and I will start to be able to
elucidate the patterns of my life and
that's really important because it's the
patterns that actually point out where
we have some struggles can I can I
circle back to the point that you were
making before about accepting the
totality of what's going on because the
journaling can help me in that yes you
know that so I mentioned before about
having maybe utilizing different pens to
speak for the different parts of
ourselves before I even go further let
me make make this observation I think
it's super helpful for you Tim to speak
openly about the ways in which there are
different parts of you you know for
those of us who are mildly curious about
this space that's an obvious fact but
there's still very much a point of view
in the world that there's just one mind
that there's just one point of view and
all those other voices we pretend aren't
there they're not part of ourselves and
you were absolutely right when those
voices are not given airtime they get
really pissed off really really angry
and the energy that they hold is really
important and so if we go back to
journaling for a moment by giving voice
to those other voices by giving airtime
to those other voices we get that layout
in fact all of the conflicts that exists
within us in Buddhism that we're taught
that there are seven layers of
consciousness seven there's an observer
observing observing observing observing
there are all these layers of what's
going on right and by taking the time in
a good journaling session you can allow
you don't even have to swap all these
pens
you can allow dialog you can allow
conflict you can allow argument and it's
in that expression that's a
manifestation of that full acceptance
that you were talking about before oh
wait I can contain multitudes
isn't that what Whitman said do i
contradict myself I do
I am large I contain multitudes amen
and we whether we aware of it or not we
all do a book that helped me a lot with
this and I found so much value in the
first I want to say 50 to 100 pages that
I wanted to get to work okay that's
plenty of grist for the mill let me get
started was radical acceptance by Tara
brach oh what a great book yeah and I
think the title is fairly sterile or
milk-toast but the book is so good and
in my particular case my default
emotional home in a way was anger and
this and the way I dealt with that was
by fighting anger if that makes sense
yes right and trying to trying to cage
and contain it and radical acceptance
offered me an entirely different way of
relating to that which I found extremely
valuable are there any other tools
meditations books anything at all that
might be helpful in assisting people to
accept or reconcile with different parts
of themselves at the very least
recognize yeah yeah differently you know
you know how before you're saying like
you you know you're taking breath
because you wanted to jump in I'm having
all those same feelings yeah so much
here first of all shout out terrible
for radical acceptance what of what a
brilliant book and what a gift she is as
a teacher yes yes yes on the acceptance
you know you talked about anger being
your default mechanism for me growing up
with the violence that I experienced as
a kid rage was a major part of my
childhood but the challenge that I
experienced was that anger rage was so
dangerous that I actually turned it into
anxiety all the time
and so actually you can't see it because
because the video is off but on my desk
or too little action figures one is Hulk
and the others Thor and one part of me
that I learned to accept was the Hulk
because the Hulk when I was a kid I
remember this one time I have a younger
brother named John and in my mind's eye
he's still 10 years old even though he's
in his 50s so a John anyway when I was a
kid we lived in a part of Brooklyn where
called Bensonhurst and I we lived in the
second floor of a two family house and I
remember looking out the window and one
day this kid was throwing rocks over the
fence at my brother John and I went
ballistic and I ran downstairs and I
grabbed this kid and I pulled him over
the fence and I threw him on the floor
and he pounded the crap out of his face
because here's the thing you do not [ __ ]
with my people you do not [ __ ] with
Hulk's people
the problem was that Hulk was often
dangerous and would often lead to
something negative happening to me so I
would shut him up and I pretend that
he's not there and he would show up in
all sorts of ways like really cleverly
dissecting somebody's argument and being
really wordy and verbose and shutting
people down and all these awful
behaviors and what I had to do was
radically accept that that guy that big
green guy exists in me for one reason
only to keep myself and those who love
me safe and by the loving Hulk I
transformed him into Thor who's just as
strong just as powerful less likely to
be out of control and motivated by
justice better hair - and much better
hair much better skin so that radical
acceptance that accepting the fullness
of of ourselves oh my god it's so
liberating isn't it yeah it is and it's
what's liberating also is simply the
realization that you can in some fashion
reconcile these different parts of you
and that they serve a purpose not only
did they serve a purpose but that they
were probably in some way fundamental to
your survival and whether that's
physical emotional or otherwise and that
they were incredibly incredibly
important and may still be very
important for certain things certain
situations but yeah but that that's
right I mean and and you know that that
recalls Carl Jung's notion of the shadow
which is the place he describes is the
place we put the dismembered parts of
ourselves and this is really important
not only do we put
parts of ourselves that society may say
are obviously not good let's say a rage
like anger but also the parts ourselves
that are actually quite powerful quite
positive and quite lovely but because
they threatened say our belonging they
have to actually be put in the shadow as
well
well they too get really pissed off
right and they to cause trouble and so
you might put into the shadow your
intellect or your capabilities or your
ability to write a book and you might
sit for the two or three decades knowing
that you want to write a book and not
doing it because it might threaten you
in some way or another this is a good
segue for difficult decisions and by
difficult I mean emotionally difficult
and so the for instance sitting on the
desire to write a book for 10 20 years
and then find hate and then finally
taking whatever the steps are the first
steps to finally write that book
potentially maybe that's leaving a job
maybe that's starting a job could be any
number of things could you speak to and
you can choose which of these questions
you would like to answer when did you
say no to something that was at the time
very difficult to say no to which in
retrospect was very important to your
life and then the other is when was a
time when you decided to kind of block
out all the noise block out everything
else and focus on something very
narrowly and that ended up being
extremely important in retrospect what
occurs to me is that the answer to both
questions is the same meaning probably
the most consequential career choice
that I made this consequential saying
know that I ever did was to walk away
from the venture business and to stop
being a professional investor
and the rest of my life unfolded and I'm
sitting here talking you today I mean we
might have been friends to him had I
taken that path who knows but where I'm
sitting here talking to you about
something that feels like the most
profound fruition of who I am my
vocation my belief systems all of this
because I said no to the thing that I
was actually really successful at which
is a mindfuck if you think about it
because it's like if I was failing as an
investor you could sort of say well of
course it walked he walked away haha he
failed but I actually walked away when I
was successful because it was too
painful how did that could you walk us
through how that happened because you
had to have this feeling for I would
imagine more than 20 minutes maybe was
days maybe was weeks maybe it was months
what was the 24 hour period that dinner
the conversation the 48 hours whatever
it might have been when you're like
enough is enough I'm actually sending
the email having the conversation and
walking yeah so it was actually years in
the making and I would have to go back
to 99 mm you know right around that time
period where if you recall the market
crashed the Nasdaq crashed I forget the
absolute numbers because they would be
miniscule compared to the numbers were
dealing with now but the market crashed
around March 1999 and I remember it
because I was on a family holiday to
Washington DC when Fred I think texted
me said did you see the Nasdaq you know
it's like oh my god you know and I think
it had dropped like 700 points or
something which at the time was like a
phenomenal number anyway right around
that time I started having this
I just couldn't sleep that there I was
just not happy and it was I was 37 38
years old so in hindsight it was clearly
entering midlife and like the systems
were collapsing all around me and then I
thought I couldn't go out and fundraise
with Fred and raise a new venture
capital fund for her flat iron and so I
decided to leave the fund but it decided
to leave the fund and go to JPMorgan
because I thought that the problem was
changing the externalities right and
it's right and so then I took a position
starting January 1st 2002 and as we were
talking about before by February it was
it's theory was just not working and I
remember going into seeing my boss at
the time a guy named Jeff Walker and
whose vice chairman of the bank he's
still a very very close friend and I
remember saying I can't do it I just
can't do it and I think it was probably
a few months after the canyon ranch
visit and I said I'm not going to renew
my contract the end of this year and he
said well what are you going to do and I
said I don't know but for the first time
in my life I'm going to be without a job
since the first time since I was about
13 and I'm going to be liberated from
this definition from this from where I
you know this notion of like wearing
somebody else's suit of clothes and it
was incredibly scary it was incredibly
hard was the trigger I hate to interrupt
but was the trigger that you had a
preset scheduled meeting for the renewal
of the contract it was kind of like [ __ ]
or get off the pot in the sense no so
you know this dinner it was a dinner
okay it was the dinner it's like Jeff I
need to have a dinner I need to talk
about this well because the presumption
everybody renewed their contract did
something prompt was there like a
particular day or moment that prompted
you asking him out to dinner it was a
growing sense that you know so I went
down to Canyon Ranch and I read these
books let your life speak a holy [ __ ]
I've actually not
and listening to my life and I started
to spend the next few months I was the
beginning of my meditation practice I
first meditated a Canyon Ranch and I
would argue I first began listening to
my life to my heart and over the next
few months up until November that year I
think we had dinner right around
November 2nd or so there's that number 2
again I never noticed that pattern
before we had dinner and I said to him
you know it was like one of those
moments do I said at the beginning of
the dinner do anything you know just one
last small hell before your partner
anymore you know and I said it at the
beginning because I needed to because we
need it and and I knew in my heart that
he would still be my friend
in fact we've we remain super close but
the fear was like what was it gonna do
and I didn't know and no idea thank you
for bringing me back to that time
because it's important for me to
remember that I'm feeling that right now
what was the day after you walked like
do you remember what that what you did
ah yeah the first one or two days after
you walked out I I remember starting to
tell people I told the woman who was my
assistant at the time she remains a very
close friend see there's a pattern
Carrie Rockland and I said you know
Carrie I'm not going to do it I don't
remember all of the details it was so
long ago this is you know 17 years ago
now but I remember the feeling and the
feeling was a combination of utter
relief and absolute terror both feelings
simultaneous what's your advice to
someone who's in that position and I'm
and I could phrase it as what advice
would you have given yourself when
feeling those two things at that point
in time which you can answer or since
you have experience with so many
executives founders and so on when
people are experiencing this sense of
relief
combined with abject terror of facing
the unknown what's your advice well the
first thing I would I would say and I
would have said to myself is that
welcome to midlife for sure
and I say this often now because I often
can see the connection to where I was
talking to this to CEO of a very
successful company who was just talking
to him this morning he's 39 years old
it's like everything's working why do I
feel groundless it's like well let's
talk about that so what I often say is
remember you're not alone and the second
is that there are there that there are
adults men and women who are on the
other side of that gulf and we're fine
and you'll be fine
and they have trod the path before you
and you're gonna be okay you know how
many references to books have you made
ten those were all written by people you
know Tara's book was written just as
much for herself as it was written for
anyone else you know and to all of those
people they're there they're like
ancestors guiding us through that period
and saying come on over the water is
fine you're gonna be okay don't be so
scared what has helped most with or what
helped most if it's past tense with your
anxiety with your worrying when you
transmuted rage into anxiety or if
anxiety bubbled up is from other sources
what are some of the things that have
helped you most with that well I'll
speak about that the the rage for a
moment the rage and then turned into
anxiety it would often turn into anxiety
but it would equally as often turn into
migraines and that's when doctors say
his first taught me the first of those
three questions which is what am I not
saying that needs to be said and by
linking speaking to the rage and to the
migraines and to the anxiety I gave
voice to the feelings and that didn't
magically make them go away but it
lessened the power of that anxiety it
lessen the power of all of those
feelings so learning to speak whether
it's in my journal or actually learning
to speak like an adult with another
human being
hey that hurt me or hey I'm scared that
thing that you said last night scared me
and as a result I want to do the thing
that I would normally do which is
withdrawing cut off connection to you
but I'm gonna stay here and be an adult
and engage with you that move it doesn't
make the anxiety go away but it puts me
back in control
puts the adult me back in control the
other thing that I do is I start to ask
the anxiety questions like you know you
won't really want to work with what's
going on in that amygdala which is where
that source of anxiety tends to be right
the amygdala ask it questions what's
what's the threat what am I afraid of
have I heard this before those questions
fire off the prefrontal cortex which can
relieve the anxiety do you ask do you
personally tend to ask those questions
before meditation in journaling what
form does the asking take yeah I do well
remember I journal before I meditate so
a lot of times I will be sitting down at
the cushion oh yeah this is
when I'm working with you know I'll tell
you what happened this morning in my
meditation session I was working with
some really difficult feelings that came
up over the weekend and I was sitting in
meditation I had had a conversation with
Sharon Salzberg yesterday and it was
really helpful in all of a sudden she
came back and just as I sat down
I'm a very ritualized meditator right so
I have candles I have incense you know
I'm a form of Catholic so I like all
that ritual stuff you know if somebody
could ring a bell it makes me happy
right so I'm doing all that stuff I'm
sitting on the cushion and all that's
emerging and all the sudden I started
visualizing the area of my chest where
my heart is
and the object of my meditation this
morning was open your heart open your
heart your heart's closing stay open
stay open and in that moment I realized
that what I was continuing to work with
was the impulse to close down this
weekend that I was feeling in response
to the fierce and so the the the
naturally arising thought that came from
that session in that moment was open
open open which very very quickly turned
into loving-kindness meditation for
myself
and for the people who don't know
correct me if I'm wrong here but
loving-kindness meditation if you want
to learn more about it but highly
recommend diving into that also known as
Metta m ET ta meditation to folks worth
checking out jack Kornfield who's been
on this podcast before specifically
speaking about meta and loving-kindness
Sharon's also spoken about it on the
podcast and those are good those are
great places to start a very very
effective short least can be short
meditation that really punches above its
weight class in a sense
I think in part for me I'm really glad
we're talking about this because it's a
type of meditation that I haven't used
in a while and I really should is at
least for me it's it's it's a vacation
from obsessing on myself if it is
directed at other people now as as was
pointed out to me during my first ever
extended meditation retreat I was
talking about loving-kindness and how
much I enjoyed it and they asked on the
way out just a quick suggestion have you
applied this to yourself at all and it
was so nonsensical to me like it didn't
it like they might have been speaking to
me in Klingon I was like loving-kindness
to myself what like that doesn't make
any sense and lo and behold I did find
it very valuable but I really enjoy
combining that with also loving-kindness
meditation for other people and if
you're just kind of rolling your eyes at
the sort of a new age hippie sounding
wording of loving-kindness then we could
switch to a different language and look
up meta mata meditation same same but
different
huh well Jared let me ask you just a
couple more questions we could we could
go for many many hours more and we we
certainly have spoken for many hours
before but for the purposes of right now
I think I think we're getting close to a
really good getting reacquainted chat
and round one of the podcast I'll ask
you just a few more questions one is
what is the new behavior in the last
handful of years it could be any time
really or belief that is most or I
should say greatly improved your life
quality of your life new behavior or
belief in the last fill in the blank
number of years that has significantly
in
prove the quality of your life I the the
mean one that comes to mind is that I am
a good man the belief that's a belief I
believe that I am a fundamentally good
person
and that I accept the fact that I often
fail to act in that in accordance with
that but that feels to this guilt-ridden
anxious ridden angry child from Brooklyn
way back when that feels radically
transformative what I'm good just as I
am know yeah I'm good yeah that's huge
hard to imagine something bigger by the
way I have to practice it every day
but you know I'm a good enough partner
I'm a good enough businessperson I'm
good enough coach I'm good enough parent
that's the hardest one for me have I
have I wounded my children yes does that
undermine whether or not I'm a good man
and a good father
no and that allowance has done something
really magical it's allowed them to
accept themselves oh yeah it's a big
move
and as a big move so the next question
might segue might be completely
different but if you could put a message
on a billboard metaphorically speaking
to get a quote a word a question
anything non-commercial out to billions
of people what would what might you put
on such a billboard I'm gonna add two
sentences but it's a big billboard so
there's a big void so it doesn't say
impeach Trump just kidding
it says you're not alone and just
because you feel like [ __ ] doesn't mean
you are [ __ ] the you are not alone is
really really important because we feel
so broken because we question our
worthiness all the time
we exacerbate the feelings of I must be
the only one who's going through this
and and this is crazy because despite
all the evidence whether it's myths
whether it's stories whether it's
religions whether it's philosophical
traditions
everybody's saying the same thing you're
fundamentally good yeah there are things
you can do to improve your life but
you're fundamentally good relax it's
okay that's that equanimity that I often
talk about it's like okay so I guess
you're not alone and just because you
feel like [ __ ] doesn't mean you are [ __ ]
and if I'm not [ __ ] then this feeling of
it being crappy right now well this will
pass so let's add another one this too
shall pass
thank you can I add on to that you can
add you can keep adding Tim think of the
times in which you have struggled you've
been very open about your struggles and
by the way thank you for doing that
because you model something that's
really important think about when you've
been at your worst and how alone it
feels and how it becomes this self
reinforcing negative view that you must
be crap because you feel like crap so
you know stop you must be human because
you feel struggle and there are billions
of humans and have been billions and
there will be billions more and struggle
is universal it is it is part of the
amusement ride
yeah and you bought a ticket go for a
ride can't be on Magic Castle
indefinitely you're gonna go through the
haunted house occasionally Jerry thank
you so much for taking the time today to
share and to catch up and to teach I
always enjoy our conversations so point
number one thank you very much well
thank you and thank you for giving me
the opportunity and thank you for asking
gorgeous questions that really help me
think and feel and thank you for doing
what you do every day it really means a
lot to the world my pleasure I really
appreciate you saying that and it helps
me as much as I hope it helps other
people and there is that weird crazy
esoteric thing that all those people
high-achieving people say oh there we go
so helping me helps other people helping
other people up to me Yeah right
Tim's living proof of that so there it's
true it's true I mean I think that you
know I've been very fortunate to somehow
stumble my way like a drunk in the dark
into this a career that involves having
conversations like this so thank you
lady fortune for that and it's it's also
just a tremendous opportunity to explore
some of these things that perhaps aren't
explored as often as they should be and
you are your great companion on the path
with that so thank you again and where
are the best places to say hello to you
on line or to learn about what you're up
to of course the book reboot subtitle
leadership and the art of growing up is
is available and certainly something I
would recommend people check out has the
many of the prompts and more that we've
talked about a lot of case studies
personal history and a distillation of a
lot of what you've learned working with
hundreds thousands of clients at this
point and what else should people know
any anything else I mean probably the
best way to sort of follow what's going
on is reboot I owe slash book but also
if you just go to the reboot dot IO
website we've got a bunch of resources
podcasts self-guided courses journaling
exercises all sorts of things designed
to help folks all for free because you
know hey what what the heck you know
let's help each other out and that's
probably the best way you can also
follow me on twitter at jerry Colonna
you mentioned that earlier but you know
pick up the book pretty proud of it and
i hope it makes makes a difference makes
a dent in the world that's that's the
best that we can hope for and for people
listening a link to everything that
we've discussed the website book website
twitter and everything else that came up
in this conversation in the show notes
as always at tim dot block forward slash
podcasts you can just search jerry JRR Y
or Colonna if you want to take the black
diamond root instead of using the easy
option and you will be able to find it
very very quickly jerry any other
comments requests anything at all that
you'd like to say before we wrap up
no it just that it was a real heartfelt
pleasure it was really a blast likewise
thanks so much jerry and everyone out
there thank you so much for listening
and until next time
pick up a damn journal amen that's right
and and real pens real pens give it a
shot it's amazing what you can discover
when you take what you think are clear
thoughts and put them on paper and
that's it for now so until next time
thanks again for listening hey guys it's
Tim again and one quick reminder if you
benefited from this podcast if you would
like to support the podcast and also get
exclusive access to me I will be doing
it an hour long live video QA every
month just for a small group of
supporters and you can learn how to do
that how it works at tim vlog forward
slash support that's tuned up log
forward slash support and you ask me
anything if you support podcasts only
supporters getting participate and ask
questions that is it tip top log that
fork slash support if you want to check
it out and that once again thank you so
much for listening hey guys this is Tim
again just a few more things before you
take off number one this is five bullet
Friday do you want to get a short email
from me would you enjoy getting a sure
email for me every Friday event provides
a little morsel of fun before the
weekend and 500 Friday is a very short
email where I share the coolest things
I've found or that I've been pondering
over the week that could include
favorite new albums that I've discovered
it could include gizmos and gadgets and
all sorts of weird [ __ ] that I've
somehow dug up in the the world of the
esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I have read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to 4-hour workweek
dot-com that's 4-hour workweek
calm all spelled out and just drop in
your email and you will get the very
next one and if you sign up I hope you
enjoy it
[Applause]
you
you